you
hi everyone is jerry garry kasparov and
Nigel short were back at it over the
board to play in a 10 game series over
two days April 25th and 26th of 2015
this was a chess exhibition pegged as
the first battle of the legends and it
was put on by the st. Louis chess club
in scholastic Center st. Louis is the
chess capital of the United States both
Kasparov in short were essentially
rekindling their match from 22 years ago
where they competed in the 1993 World
Chess Championship match in this battle
the legends they played five games on
each day each day consisting of one
rapid time control game 25 minutes
10-second increment and four blitz games
with time control five minutes and a
three-second increment I'll be showing
all ten games in this one video and
providing some very brief commentary
along the way additionally on the right
hand side you'll notice I've popped up
the stockfish engine so it gives you a
little bit of an idea as to how the
evaluation is shifting from move to move
as I go through each of these ten games
so let's hop right to it and see went on
let's see what went on in this battle
the legends we have on day one game one
of the rapid time control game Kasparov
on the white end kicking off with D for
short replying with e6 Knight f3 Knight
f6 we soon turn into a BOGO Indian
defense with Bishop b4 on Knight B to d2
we have what's known as the Grunfeld
variation black is striking at the white
center we're soon to have now this minor
peace and balance Knight for Bishop
exchange black taking opening up the
position getting on with some developing
moves striking in the center the queen
is there to recapture exerting some
pressure on g2 this makes life a little
bit difficult for y to complete King
side development so white seeks a queen
exchange but black is not so quick to do
so retreating and maintaining pressure
so f3 is on board a step in the
direction to develop the bishop
the Knights kicked v5 freeing the bishop
and now we have efore these next few
moves
efore soon we're going to have both
Queen and Bishop moving next and this is
to anticipate an eventual knight move
into that B 3 square certainly a soft
point on the White Queen side so II for
97 Queen f2 not yet doing anything with
the light square Bishop Knight c5 Bishop
e3 the night lands in there but the rook
not so inconvenienced he wanted to go to
d1 anyway this is an open file so we
have both light square Bishop scumming
out neither side with an advantage
timewise development wise and the main
imbalance here is that White has the
bishop pair this x-factor Bishop so how
to put him to use how to show his power
on board black regroups the knight
repositions the knight so that this f6
can xf6 move can be played to reinforce
e5 Kasparov put some pressure on e5
right away it's supported but now
looking to break open the position
cracking at that dark square e 5 like d4
Bishop h5 maintaining the bishops the
rook is hit but it's simply ignored
smashing through on e5 allowing this
exchange sacrifice Bishop takes rook
rook takes Bishop and you cannot
recapture on e5 this is getting broken
down very fast all white pieces are
functioning quite well do not forget
about the knight soon to pounce on the
position by way of d5 there is no time
to recapture this Queen is excellent
this Knight is hit bishops head there's
checking ideas and there's even back
rank maid ideas once the King is in the
corner should the knight play like this
just getting out of the way well here
comes this final piece this is deadly as
you're seeing the evaluation is plus 9
and climbing deadly fork coupled with
this idea of rook f8 that's going to be
game over cannot take here 1 stride is
king h8
and now Knight d5 giving the exchange
back is black clean f2 exerting pressure
on the knight a better continuation
would have been Queen to h4 with this in
mind exploiting the pin against the king
instead the knight centers himself up
the exchange is given back and now we
have black basically crawling into a
ball just barely getting back for
defense Bishop h6 threatening a matin -
now with Queen takes pawn and then mate
the knight hurries back to block and we
have the bishop pair versus a sad night
and a rook that is yet to contribute
he's getting into play now white is
regrouping a little bit a little bit of
a well slight edge for over white here
an idea would be Bishop to d2 to c3 to
consolidate as was mentioned by Kasparov
after this game or after the after day
ones games just to consolidate get the
bishops on nice squares here and this
King is going to be in some big trouble
and it's much much easier to play on the
white side being really well coordinated
but instead Bishop b4 rook e8 still
maintaining pressure on the knight
maintaining this knight in a pin d4
offer the Queen exchange that's avoided
rook takes Bishop in we end up having
with this first game a perpetual check
Bishop takes Queen takes and now this
Queen bounces back and forth on these
two squares here d8 + f6 and these two
players agree to a draw there's no way
to avoid the perpetual check this was
game one of day one and the only draw of
the entire 10 games which is really
something so let's dive right in and see
this first now the Blitz game Game two
of day one we have short on the white
end kicking off with c4 we see in this
one
the English opening what's known as the
ultra symmetric
variation copycat variation if you would
like to view it like that but we we
quickly have an imbalance truck in this
position right away this is an
interesting night maneuver looking to
prevent this d5 advance let's see how
black deals with that h4 h6 on board so
as to meet a tribe with g5 giving the
night a kick Queen d2 this is preparing
b3 and Bishop to b2 finishing some
development but this is where black
strikes right away b5 pawn sacrifice
takes takes takes whites up a pond but
now this d5 move is on board so the this
idea the time spent with this Knight
maneuver on 2f into that f4 square well
black is finding a way to give up some
material just to get this pawn advanced
in a very nice center a knight that is
now going to be struck out right away
Bishop a6 series of captures the light
square bishop s' are now going to be
exchanged white needs to be a little bit
careful of their dart of their light
squares possibilities for Knight jumping
into f3 at some stage there is no light
squared bishop that black has but the
Queen can certainly function on this
diagonal at some stage this is a weak
pawn but white is white is holding it's
a as you can see we valuation wise it's
about an equal position but this is
going to be a really strong Knight at
some stage jumping jumping into that d4
point f5 on board f4 very weakening but
still a close call here in this game to
first blitz game night centers up takes
takes rook is getting active on the
black side and we have this doubling up
looking for quite possibly h5
undermining this structure rook III it's
hard to pick a better Square for that
rook he's no longer just a piece
functioning along a file but here comes
some rank pressure pressure on g3 this
Knight is
well I can't move now g3 would drop
Brooke f3 trying to neutralize that
rooks pressure along the rank and just
doubling up is Black Knight f4 Queen b7
defending now against f3 Queen a6 I
didn't see it at the moment or at the
time this game was being played I was
thinking more just Queen a6 to try and
pick up that pond but there's also this
idea to have an eye on that g6 square as
we'll see b3 the Queen's there to defend
Bishop e5 h5 Bishop takes and now this
intermediate recapture instead of taking
the bishop right here this capture here
is going to be the game loser after pawn
takes we have the Queen recapturing you
can't recapture like this because of
rook takes g3 there goes your queen
and after pawn takes what's going to
happen well the move played in the game
Queen h5 big trouble
rook g8 right around the corner rook
takes pawn takes this is now a passed
pawn - connected passed pawns usually
really good but they're a long way off
from posing any threat at all this guy
is going to be deadly
Queen h2 just getting out of this pin
idea king h1 in now e - and that is game
over as you see on the right hand side
it's already calling for a mate and
three once the rook do you go here Queen
f3 Queen g2 next and well where else are
you going to go up on take struck
promoting to a queen it's just deadly
here promotion there's no save at this
point so Kasparov going up here now one
and a half to half let's see what
happened in Game two or I should say
game 3 blitz game number 2 where we have
Kasparov on the wide end he's opening up
with the e4 and we see now the news of
edge defense some interesting openings
we have a really good blend in these 10
games
a really great variety of different
openings being played so in this one
it's the nimzowitsch defense let's see
how this one plays out a little bow is a
little bit awkward to obstruct that see
pun runs into this tempo gaining move
but that's what Black is baiting white
to do just to make these guys flinch
they're quite often best place sitting
like this but as soon as one moves
forward there's a little bit of a gap
and the in the position the e5 square in
particular this does happen
d5 the knight returns home it should be
- just getting some developing moves in
here trying to grab some Queen side
space is white and now welcoming this
exchange here it is still a bit of a
closed position Black has some nice
control over these dark squares and we
have c6 a five a six the first square
that pops up is b6 that's a weak square
and something that white focus is in on
we have the bishop soon the night
looking to jump into that square black
develops a piece Bishop d4 just getting
some more pieces involved all pieces
involved in here comes the knight Knight
b6 right around the corner 'if I've the
bishop for Knight exchange the rook is
hit this Knight can soon be challenged
with the knight on D 7 but we have a
nice little rook lift looking to
reinforce the knight 97 rook b3 quite
timely striking now in the center is
black this is weakening the light
squares if there's ever a capture or
push there's maybe ideas of getting the
bishop in here don't know how dangerous
that would be with the position
simplifying quite a bit more not as many
minor pieces on board more of a heavy
piece ending Knights are exchanged
getting the Queen involved now c5 rook
to b6 we saw this in the previous game
Kasparov's rook coming down here
functioning no longer on the not just
down the file but the rank similar story
here there's some pressure on the weak
point d6 so let's see how this plays out
for c4 we have
queenside break now with be for all
rooks here trained now on the B file
rook takes rook takes a five queen b1
stopping any rook check if you go right
in for this there's here and king h2 you
could block king h2 this might be a bit
of an annoying idea to give that King
another check this is stopped altogether
queen bee one queen d8 rook takes pawn
Queen f6 so this is threatening a
capture and maybe smashing through on
this square if this Queen is no longer
around to watch over efore rook is there
to defend a little bit black's getting
active with their rook there might be
some sacrifices here against the white
king side c5 d take C the rooks are
exchanged after King h8 we have the move
Queen c2 but before this move was played
in the game
Kasparov ran out of time he played the
move Queen c2 and it was at that point
that nigel then pointed to his clock
Kasparov was down on time and lost this
third game of 10 so he was in the
driver's seat clearly but he'd lost
track of time he's been out of it for a
little bit and he lost track of time on
this one this is uh now a score of one
and a half each so it's split at this
point let's have a look at this next
game game for Game four from day one
short now on the white end b3 I was not
lying when I said that we had quite a
bit of a mix the nimzowitsch Larsson
attack b3 system okay so let's see how
this plays out white goes with a double
fiend keto system white sets up a nice
black sets up a nice pawn center III
knight c6 exchanging some night soon we
actually have a damage structure now
after d4
these pieces are off the light square
bishop in particular and white needs to
take some care over there light squares
as a result of this these two can be
without question a long-term long-term
disadvantage for sure these double
isolated ponds we have as a follow-up d3
and then Queen to d7 this is already a
super super important point in the game
what ends up happening after Queen d7
and then Queen to e2 black takes on III
and this is as it turns out just a very
poor structure for white
these guys are doubled and isolated but
the amount of pressure that black is
able to exert on this white d3 pond and
also this idea of launching the H pond
as you'll soon see white is the side
who's really crawling up into a ball and
it's just not a fun position to play
black maybe could have even done one
move better by capturing first on III
prior to a Queen move after Queen to d7
white should consider capturing like
this just to mask this pond don't to
another words not allow this heavy piece
pressure against the d3 pond or even
consider efore to close it up a little
bit this would allow still some play on
the black side with that Queen pond
lying a5 a4 and then there will be some
target on the Queen side of the board
but it's hard to imagine that it would
it would the white position would
collapse like it did in this game we had
Queen e2 D take C F takes and now just
getting some pressure on d3 having to go
completely defensive and hit now in
comes h5h for striking at these two
ponds it's a very weak King position
robbed of the LightSquared Bishop robbed
of the F pawn and a lot of gaps in the
white position f3 and h3 in particular
9c3 finishing development but here comes
now night G for improving the night
position opening up the bishops diagonal
and immediately there is the threat of
night take c3 with bishop d4 to follow
and there goes the Queen so white
exchange dark square bishop s-- pressure
now on e3 having to babysit another pawn
rook e1 h4 on board just breaking open
the position for what exactly well in
comes now King g7 don't forget about
this rook soon to enter the position in
fact of both rooks soon to enter along
the H file Queen g2 really just trying
to defend there's not much that you
could do there's not a great active plan
here for the white side simple idea
double rooks smash through here smash
through there and what do you do so
completely naked King here there's no
there's no good defense h3 the knight is
kicked it's not much of an inconvenience
not much of an inconvenience he's really
well central he's now with in checking
distance and there's even ideas right
now to capture on this square at some
stage with Knight f3 to follow but we
just have a little bit of a build-up
rook d h8 eat our d4 and that returns
ready to get into this square next this
pawn will fall soon and is hit a ton of
times H 3 will then be hit a ton of
times an ID 3 knight f2 defending here
comes another piece offering a queen
exchange trying to alleviate the
pressure but we have this intermediate
check King f1 really ugly looking pawns
right but this King is still going to be
under some heavy fire king e to look H
to the Knights in a pin avoiding the
rook exchange looking for this move next
and this is a game over move next right
here Knight g4 you can't do anything
about that these threats here rope takes
III rook takes f2 this is completely
collapsing rook takes c3
rookie for this night is still pinned
rook takes rook takes giving up the
exchange but there's nothing to do here
this Knight is now in a pin and afteri
five nigel he just throws in the towel
at this point it's at what two and a
half to one and a half at this stage
they have one more game to play in day
one let's see what happened in this
final game of day one here their fourth
blitz game where Kasparov finishes up
day one with the white pieces he opens
up with d4 what do we have in this game
the chigorin defense okay
this was an interesting battle not a
well we have a really quick imbalance
the knight for Bishop exchange in a
messed up pawn structure here double def
cons III queen is hit the knight is
pinned that's broken bishop pair versus
the Knights ideally black would like to
have the position closed let's see if he
manages Queen B one with an eye on b7
and also a checking square on f5 for
when black castles now this was a really
interesting idea f4 and after it takes
to give this check and then recapture
the Queen's are off board Knight f6 the
bishop pair versus the Knights in the
position get opened up more we're going
to see that f5 it's defended and here we
go it's in fact black who's opening up
the position trying to exploit these two
pieces two bishops that are unprotected
we does win upon but it's only
temporarily after the rook recaptures
the center is completely liquidated and
here's the dark square bishop skewing
the rook pawn and soon to hit the rook
in the corner rook to e8 d1 this is just
a fantastic position for the black side
the King is fine over here on g3 not
accessible the Knights are of no bother
to the white side
we have now rook d6 pressure on this
night here and now we have rook takes
Knight not the best move
computer suggests rook to d7 maintaining
the rook pressure on b7 pressure on f7
following up
we did have rook takes Knight if the
rook is captured immediately we have
this idea in mind but in response short
is able to first do what take out the
bishop and then after the recapture take
the rook so this is an equal position
these pawns are close to producing a
passed pawn this is a two-to-one
majority with regard to the E and F
files alone here this last move is
cutting the King off he's not easy he
won't be able to easily approach these
pawns here and help out so let's see how
this plays out rook takes the king is
now moving up the board the pawns are
set into motion avoiding the rook
exchange keeping a close eye on a 7h for
preserving that pun and these guys get
marching Black has to be very accurate
King is improving a little bit here
black is up upon but this is a very
dangerous pawn
just a couple steps away rook d1 King up
6 little check is thrown in here comes
the black King closer to now helping out
escort these two passed pawns they are
split but they're both passed rook d7 a4
it's raised it's a big race King e6
Knight f6 there to defend e7 now black
gives up that pawn or that night for the
pond is very dangerous pun and there's
ways that black can actually draw this
as we will see rook c8 d3 we have this
point right here after rook a7 h4 again
recognizing the time situation not a lot
of time to be doing this type of
calculation but black had this move rook
takes Bishop
and after king takes to push forward and
this will turn out to be a draw just
rooks e7 c3 and the timing is just right
but there's a lot of calculation that
goes into that if I'm to play out just a
little bit more King b3 I'm not sure
what's even considered best at this
point that's computer suggests rook b2
King a to rook g1 king b2 this will turn
out to be a draw King f8 c2 King g7 you
could promote and the timing is just
going to be right for both sides here
they both Queen at the same time that's
a very deep calculation to run with at
this point seeing that this does in fact
work out was not played instead rook d7
offering a rook exchange these pawns get
moving a little bit white is hunting
down this pond and he's very close to
queening c3 pawn has taken black King is
improving and after King b3 noticed the
evaluation it's a tipping in White's
favor quite a bit but this is actually
not accurate the stock fish engine it's
a bit misleading here the stock fish
engine is not recognizing yet that this
is in fact a completely equal position
after King takes rook that's a losing
move c2 better would have been to simply
promote right away after rook takes
Queen King takes rook promote push and
this is going to be a draw cannot push
through successfully and now computer
finally recognizes that this is
completely equal can't do anything King
f7 there's the big problem is this idea
of stalemate could do this sort of stuff
just to show really quick here King just
keeps coming over like this the queen is
getting closer you could give a check
you could go here that's the main idea
on Queen takes pawn this is stalemate
but this was missed a 1 was not played
surprisingly enough instead it was see
two white promotes black promotes and
now we have check another check queen or
Queens or exchange and it's at this
point that short resigns again after
King takes Queen there goes the pawn and
that's game over so not a great end to
day one for sure
there was this seemed pretty
straightforward but then again I'm not
the one playing over the board there's
not that that type of stress that I have
or the clock situation none of that so
but yeah it was this move first and then
push through and it's going to be a it's
going to be a drop so that was the end
of day 1 day 1 finishing up three and a
half to one and a half
what would day to bring let's see day
two started out the same way as day 1
with the rapid time control game short
on the white end and this one efore and
we see with this the Sicilian nigh Dorf
an open Sicilian night off with a 6 and
we have g3p 5 this was a these were my
two well this game here was probably my
favorite of these 10 games certainly a
much higher quality that's for sure and
you know there is more time so it's to
be expected but a really interesting
fight in this one big big point of
emphasis in this game is the d5 square
this is the weakest Square in the black
position and we see white eventually
maneuvering to get into that point
getting all the pieces active half open
file preparing to castle Bishop e7 black
however does not castle in this game
keeping the rook on AJ and looking to
break out the break open the H file that
continues on this little journey to go
where exactly
III and then d5 or f5h 493 g6 just keeps
that night out and now rook to e2 what's
the idea behind rook to e2 white would
really like to play this move here and
at the end of all these exchanges
recapture with the Queen but that would
drop c2 so rook to e2 is going to defend
this so that this move is now back on
it's very important for black to now be
timely and he goes in for this exchange
sacrifice it is the top move being
suggested by the computer it was in fact
the move played H takes G and then with
this idea rook takes c3 exchange
sacrifice wrecking the White Queen side
structure and it's not just the exchange
black also scoops up upon a very
significant pond a central pawn so black
with a two to zero majority in the
center not so healthy pawn structure
over here for the white end let's see
how this one plays out it should be -
not the happiest move in the world to
have to play devoting a piece to
defending that weak pawn if that weak
pun on c3 Knight f6 c4 looking to jump
into that d5 square Queen c8 has some
ideas along the C file and maybe ideas
connected with that h3 square in the
game we have Knight g5 and we have some
coordination happening on that h3 square
like d5 Knight takes pawn takes in comes
Knight g5 computer does like the white
side here about a pawn and then some
advantage something about upon advantage
c4 a 5 looking to get this Bishop here
this is this is really well defended
point on d5 so the bishops looking to
finally have some pressure on the white
position putting pressure on c4 well at
least a piece will then be
inconvenienced on the whites
the queen or rook will have to watch
over that point rook c1 should be a six
clean g4 just getting very active
staying coordinated now the rooks are
defended the bishop is returning there's
not going to be a way to crash through
on c4 the Bishop's looking to reroute
the other idea is that white is ready to
take this pawn black sees this and
doesn't want to have to then be reacting
at that stage so it's a pre-emptive move
bishop c8 not allowing that eventual
tempo against the bishop bishop c8 on
board and now f4 really looking to blast
open the position hitting the knight
crashing through on e5 potential pins
along the e-file there's already an
immediate pin against this rook on h8
following up knight h3 he cannot be
taken Bishop takes rook takes and this
is going to be game over pawn takes here
there's no longer this pin this is
crashing through you need this guy
around to watch over your light squares
King f1 f6 just reinforcing that a
5-point not allowing this bishop to
break through so easily offering the
Queen exchange it's avoided rookie for
King f7 Queen exchange being offered now
by black Queens are off and after D
takes a this is now opening up a new
diagonal for the bishop so still we have
material-wise white is the better side
but the quality of the piece is the the
bishop pair this knight and rook let's
see what I can do with this one
rook h4 less is apparently a slip not
much time keep in mind I don't know how
accurate the times are it does give us
some ideas to where they were in the
game time wise but did not like this
move here short at about well under a
minute rook h4 gives something away here
this is not a good structural change
this pawn is a little bit more away from
the center
makes these moves maybe a bit more
effective these are now what we can say
to connected past ponds with this pond
no longer being on the g3 square so
Knight f4 repositioning with tempo and
it's very interesting to see how these
pieces really coordinate just an amazing
way they just no inconveniencing the
rook how does he even get active d6
Bishop gives a check now all of a sudden
whites in a pin black and pick up the
exchange but what a cool move this is
I'm not taking your rook I'm hunting
down this pawn I'm going to have a past
a pawn black is saying essentially I
prefer the bishop pair than to give up
or to get the exchange back just
hammering away at a four a four drops
with check the other pawn falls and this
is just completely collapsing here comes
the e pawn the F pawn sad state for the
bishop he's now in the corner he's
basically not even on the board now
doing anything bishop d1 rook due to
eventually white gives the exchange back
but there's just way too many pawns here
a for b5 simplifying even more for pawns
three pawns to one and there's just
nothing to do at this point short ends
up resigning this game as well so real
mountain to climb not looking very good
at all let's see what these these are
last four games bring for blitz games
where we have Kasparov on the white end
in this one he opens up with d4 Knight
f6 what was the opening we saw on this
one this was considered the accelerated
Queen's Indian a very quick b6 not
playing let's say e6 first but instead
b6
we have f3 looking to just build in the
center with E for C 3 e 5 White has the
space
I found this quite interesting not
playing that efore move so quickly
instead III seems a bit awkward to do it
like that right you have f3 you would
think well you're doing that to get e4
in but what's the idea behind this is to
keep some control over these dark
squares anticipating that this Knight
well maybe one day he wants to jump into
f4 that's not going to be allowed so
just watching over some squares here
offsetting the e5 pawn one might view it
as that c6 striking at d5 Knight h3 now
e4 comes on board only after this Bishop
has put some more pressure on that point
upon was being threatened here hit a
bunch of times both Knights pawn and
Bishop another defender is needed so
only at that point is e 4 being played
like g6 Bishop e3 dark square bishop SAR
exchange and now with d6 this board is
really cut right in half this Bishop is
a very sad piece just staring at the
pawn and this pawn is quite weak black
black castles Queen d2 b3 not just there
to reinforce c4
it's paving the way for Knight a for to
hunt down that c5 pawn upon that's very
difficult to defend I mean what do you
do with both the knight and queen put
pressure on that he can easily fall
Queen a three-night a for what might be
better than Queen to a3 computer
suggests rook F to e8 believe this move
can still be played Queen takes d2 King
takes okay
there would then be rook to e6 scooping
up that pawn instead it was Queen a
three-night a4 offering a queen exchange
this does happen the Queen's aren't off
the board
C takes B this allows c5 tremendous
space advantage here with these ponds
and they're ideally placed fixed on dark
squares complementing that light square
Bishop quite well and there's now a nice
square for the
LightSquared Bishop Knight gems into e6
this is the most vulnerable point most
vulnerable square on the white side but
you know my my feeling with this is that
with these puns so far advanced there's
already ideas of giving up the exchange
if this night somehow becomes
intolerable in the game it's not
necessary to do something like that but
just seeing the closed nature of the
position giving up an exchange a rook
for a knight this really bad bishop if
this pawn is ever being pushed with
ideas of Bishop a8 a six exchanging
LightSquared bishop s-- that would
weaken the b6 square it's just a very
closed position this is the only square
that black has the only positive feature
in the black position is that d4 square
but it's never really going to be enough
Knight f2 is reminding black that this
pawn is weak Knight d3 how are you even
defending e5 a5 rooks e1 here comes
Knight f4 this Knight has had an
interesting journey
he's now recycling all the way back to
g6 to baby said that e5 pawn it's just
not looking good at all light square
bishop SAR exchanged 93 h4 and these
guys end up getting crushed this is a
tremendous space advantage I can't speak
highly enough or I can't speak enough
about this space advantage that white
has on the Queen side Knight b6 putting
pressure on that pawn black pieces are
going to be tied down it's just not a
happy position at all for the black side
f4 grabbing some more space playing on
both sides now is white and after f5
this Knight is completely dead these two
pawns here and well one might consider
this pawn here is contributing to
killing this knight this pawn could
never move due to this pawn he can never
go here here because of this guy and if
he ever goes here
so what where is it going next here he
can't it's a completely locked out
Knight
he's in the corner he's dead it's just
an absolutely crushing position the
whole board has been controlled by the
white side Knight f7 rook f3 let's see
how this plays out the knight is
entering the position and I really do
mean the whole board is being made use
of a rook a1 doing what exactly
a3 on board next breaking on the Queen
side a little bit but white is not going
to budge with this pawn here King here
is played just to prevent this eventual
pawn advance for example at this point
after here if just making a dummy move
after this capture the recapture this
pawn can start to move so it's just a
slow improving King position improvement
here King d3 if black is taking at this
stage you simply recapture and now
there's no e4 in fact there's just now a
nice square for the f2 Knight so instead
King g7 very difficult to recommend
anything here for the black side rook be
7 the a file is now going to be opened
up the evaluation is climbing in White's
favor look at the King positions if you
compare King positions this Knight still
dead this is the only active piece but
he's under control he's not of any
threat to the white side following up
black is preparing an exchange sacrifice
but it's not going to be enough white
just neutralizes the most active piece
rook d3 there go the rooks and simply
defend this pawn he remains dead and now
white can improve their King position
and there's absolutely nothing that
black can do to stop that
in fact after King to c5 it's at that
point that black resigns there's nothing
to do great control over this one big
squeeze in the center Queen side of the
board I should say first nice play with
establishing this pawn on f5 and then
play over here again opening up the a
file there was nothing that black could
do
he resigned in this position here after
king c5 how might it play out computer
first off was just suggesting Knight
takes f5 so that's how bad this position
is if Knight g4 there's b5 there's rook
f3 keeping him under control and ideas
like rook a 3a a and then D a let me
show just something like this I don't
know what to suggest for black but just
just show the idea on the white side
rook here how do you defend the pawn you
could play here but now the king is
overloaded having to watch over both the
knight and pawn Knight takes pawn and
white is smashing through Knight here
next so it's just a hopeless position
here for for black and with that after
game 7 it's five and a half to one and a
half in fact after this game here it's
already locked up there's no way that
short could win so these three games
still were played out let's see how this
finishes up we have short in this eighth
game now he's playing on the white side
game opens up with e4 we have a Sicilian
open Sicilian with a slightly awkward
move order here playing to e2 but okay
eventually the knight gets into that d4
square recapturing we have this Richter
rouser attack with Bishop g5 Queen d2
she's getting some developing moves in
here h4 King b1 some natural stuff but
now f4 that's quite interesting right
give up that bishop he's not taking
instead Black is developing taking
allows the recapture the knight is hit
and soon that Queen could shift over to
the a file I could be big big problems
for the black side evaluation is already
in favor of the white side here so not
taking on this square instead developing
more pieces need to get involved dark
square Bishop is now well this is the
x-factor bishop
unopposed dark square bishop we have e5
breaking open the position black is
fully developed this is an interesting
point in the game a five hits the bishop
on pawn takes the move played in the
game it does drop the bishop but
apparently this has all been worked out
by Kasparov he did the calculations and
did them well Queen takes bishop efore
unmasking that bishop he will not be
denied sight of this Queen side the
knight v2 pond 95 trying to block that
Bishop well we have Bishop takes Knight
pawn takes rook a to d8 another piece or
in pawn is taken Queen takes B rook
takes the knight is having to recapture
now this allows for Queen e1 talk about
a super active piece threatening mate
and one Bishop e2 defends this drops the
rook what might have been something
better well there should be two is best
and I have to go for that the only way
to defend what would happen on King c1
well rook to d8 what are you doing about
this Knight so Bishop e2 the apparent
best there goes the rook
there goes black's knight getting the
last piece involved this is a passed
pawn made is threatened on d1 how to
cope with that B for providing a flight
square but now in comes Queen e1 it's a
very nice move not Kat Netta cashing out
here grabbing some material and there's
more that black can get in this position
one might think why not go in for that
and then push with e3 but this would
allow a check and then another check and
he scooped up so instead it's Queen e1
still trying to put some kind of an
attack against that white King Queen
takes a queen takes B with check King c1
another check another check now really
bad position what do you do King here's
mate and well King here that's me
so you have to block and now the big
question is do you take the knight or do
you take the bishop you definitely take
the
shup you don't want him glued into that
b5 square so you go after the bishop and
as soon as he's gone this is a really
really sad night here what stride is
Knight c3 there goes another pawn and
after e3 black is reminding white that
he's not only up material but he has
this past pawn and very poor King
position it's at this point that short
he resigns again it's a I don't know
this really turned out to be a beating
and a half of an exhibition I must say
it's really it was really incredible and
we're not even finished yet
there's two more games that was game
eight two games remaining it was just
really amazing stuff to see let's see
this ninth game we're almost there
we have Kasparov on the white end
starting out with E 4 we have a Kings
Indian attack in this one really neat
mix of openings in this series I really
enjoyed this Bishop e2 this was an
interesting game another attacking game
every game was an attacking game somehow
at some stage in many of the games it
starts out positional but then some type
of dynamism is injected into the
position it just gets really really
crazy a lot of fun to watch for the
spectators for sure I have white
building in the center the battle lines
are drawn White's heading in this
direction playing where they have space
this pawn on e5 black this is where they
have space over here on the Queen side
and that's where they will be looking to
play starting with c4 here and now b5 so
the direction black is going in white
should be looking to attack the black
king and this is the start of it Knight
g4 a4 a3 not allowing the a3 brake
allowing a3 makes this pawn flinch and
then he starts to become a bit
vulnerable the whole structure starts to
become vulnerable so
a three stops this idea right away
secure c3 d4 is secure as a result and E
5 is all the more secure not only are
the pieces there but this structure is
now really really strong for as long as
you're not allowing that a3 break to
happen B take C you pretty much have to
do that
playing b3 that's not the direction to
go and black needs to open the queenside
so B take C B takes getting to an open
file giving up upon but trying to get
some play on the queenside white takes
that on offer Queen a8 avoids the Queen
exchange white is looking for blood here
going after the black King h5 the night
is now kicked to e3 he really wants to
get back to that g4 square black Devils
g4 on board
this is opening up that g4 square trying
to eliminate that pun and then get right
back in here and on top of that it's the
G file that now will open up H takes G
Knight takes rook moves up so that the
Queen can now come over here to defend
will soon see that rook g1 Queen here
this is the idea that white has as soon
as the replace to G one night to h6 if
let's say Knight b3 at this stage Knight
h6
and what do you do if you go here you're
dropping this pawn King h8 drops the
pawn and if you go here well this is
inviting the most powerful piece in the
position mate threat here on mate thread
on g8 and also looking to just smash
through on g7 so black comes over to
defend in order to meet Knight h6 with
King to h8 this would prevent white from
entering Queen h7 but as we can see
there's just going to be still something
no matter what black does here
already a plus two and climbing Bishop
g5 top move repeat ooh Queen c1 it just
continues to climb and white just
absolutely pounces on the black position
Bishop h6 there's a ton of winning moves
+7 and smashing right through you cannot
take that bishop there's absolutely no
way it's making - Knight f6 King here
that's me so white pieces are just
circling the black King inching closer
and closer smashing through on f7 look
out 6 c6 is falling and now it looks as
if black queenside castle but instead it
was just a very long and painful march
all the way over to that V 8 square
there's no defense here +4 always at
least and giving up the Queen but
there's just no hope after rook g1
there's just nothing to do one idea to
try and have this make it one threat
well there goes your rook so an
exchanging rooks these two are just
deadly and don't forget that he's passed
in three squares away from queening so
with that we enter the final game the
10th game many spectators I imagine
rooting for short to try and stop the
bleeding maybe come away with at least a
draw but that did not happen
let's see the final decisive game here
short on the white end going with the
Tauri attack let's see how this one
plays out black eventually hunts down
this Bishop yeah at this point right
here after C 3 we have g5 9 h5 and one
little instructive point here is the
moment when exactly to take that bishop
well not right away there's a little bit
of a waiting game going on here why not
take the bishop well it's hoping it's
opening up the rook maybe you take on
this square only after castles that's
really the the train of thought that's
going on at this at this point here you
could take at this stage here but
instead more development he's not
going anywhere it's usually the case
that the bishop will be pending the
night but in some sense it's kind of
like the night is pinning the bishop
he's really a piece that can't move in
this current position whereas the knight
has options so trying to grab some Queen
side spaces white with a four here comes
out five and this is reminding white
that well you know what I might not just
want to take your Bishop but maybe even
trap your bishop in some instances
ninety one pressure on that night he's
still not committing getting another
piece involved making way for the bishop
to develop as well and there might be
ideas of queenside castle one other idea
that white had with a four is well if
black is playing these moves here does
he really want to go with kingside
castle if he's going Queen side white is
that much closer to creating some pond
tension and opening up the Queen side of
the board in the game we didn't have
that the King ends up residing on the
King side f4 is on board only then does
the knight capture the bishop he was
quite possibly ready to run away
although you know what that would drop
the f4 upon but it is at this moment
Knight takes bishop is on board pawn
takes black castles and now e4 open
trying to open up the position but it is
black who has the bishop pair need to be
careful here for sure
we have c5 striking at the center
looking to open up the position is
really both sides it's quite interesting
to see that e4 and now black is
insisting no I'm going to open up the
position even further striking at d4
keep in mind it's this guy here who's
the unopposed bishop dark square bishop
if d 4 is square that the bishop can
make use of at some stage this is a
deadly threat the King forced to this
side of the board and don't forget about
this square here a queen could very
easily sneak over and deliver deliver
that final blow to the white king
they're giving checkmate
so white takes here not allowing this
sequence of moves this capture capture
because then that's an accessible point
for that Bishop at some stage so it's
instead D take C and not to recapture
but instead black bypasses that pond
with d5 striking it efore and making way
for the Queen to capture that pawn with
check this is a very nice sequence of
moves here c5 takes d5 we have e takes F
Queen takes pawn first with check only
then recapturing this is now a beautiful
square for a knight to jump into don't
forget about G for either
- fantastic jumping points for that
Black Knight computer does like the
black side here Queen III really deep in
the white position here hitting at g3
keeping pressure on f4 keeping pressure
on everything this Knight not a great
piece at all Queen f3 offering a queen
exchange really cool move Queen EA
avoiding the Queen exchange having ideas
of Queen to h5 Knight g4 and then Queen
to h5 Knight c2 looking to regroup hung
up that d4 square look and get that
final piece involved but now comes
Knight g4 threatening a mate and one two
kingi one Queen h5 rook e1 on Queen h2
the Kingston simply sneaks over black
does not go in for that right away
instead develops a little bit needs more
firepower going right in for Queen h2
Queen h1 King e - how do you really get
at the King black is recognizing he
needs more material more firepower on
board Bishop d7 Queen takes pawn with
check black is giving up a pawn with
check and now a bishop but now here
comes the Queen Queen h2 Queen soon to
make use of the h1 square but first
getting another piece involved skewering
the queen and the bishop queen picks up
a
this bishop can be taken but now here
comes Queen takes g3 not even bothering
to pick up the bishop instead grabbing
on g3 threatening made on f2 F for is
hit this is completely dead minus five
and climbing rookie - there goes the
bishop Knight c5 another pawn is taken
with Czech Queen g3 check King f1 it's
just a constant constant punch being
thrown at white and he's having to react
to all these different threats Queen h1
was being threatened no time for Knight
takes rook Queen h1 game over g3 rook
takes and there's absolutely nothing to
do there was a mate threat on g7 it's
defended Knight takes bishop how do you
recapture well there's only one of two
what there's only one way to recapture
the knight but you just don't even
recapture this Knight he's of no bother
to black instead Knight h2 the computer
is already reading out am 8 and 10 kingi
1 there's already discovered checks in
the air what's played is Knight f3 check
King f2 rook discovered check Queen f4
check King d3 in this 10 game series
this 10 game exhibition ends with a cool
95 nice centralization of the night
double-check and that's mate I'm really
out of words for this kind of play I've
really never witnessed that kind of a I
don't know what you would want to call
it feel free to fill in the blank what
just went on here it's really incredible
this finished up after these two days
playing rapid time control and two games
at rapid eight games at blitz it
finished up eight and a half to one and
a half the half game drawn from game one
was one that was just to save like a
really really good save there was a lot
of pressure on Nigel in game 1 and he
managed to draw that game the other game
was a loss on time by Kasparov he was
doing well in that game the game that he
lost on time and then we have all other
eight games
there's just really really amazing stuff
I just don't know what more to add
really feel free to share what your
thoughts are on this exhibition there's
battle of the legends this is again
regarded as the first battle of the
legends what might the second battle of
the legends be if there is even going to
be something like that question to you
is which two legends would you see would
you like to see battling it out if there
is a second battle the legends feel free
to leave any feedback in the comment
section below
I hope you enjoyed me covering these ten
games I had fun doing this and watching
it live as well so that's all for this
video as always I hope you got something
out of it take care bye
you
[Music]